plane crash looks really nice that's
clearly all CG today we're going to do
the fattest of the rocks and the
trimmest of the Rock right one of the
heads is a 3D model good we're talking
like a Straight Up 3D model Straight Up
3D model
oh no how would you guys do this shot if
you have to do this shot let me get my
uh
how do I do this
before we get into react I'm going to
spruce up the studio a little bit with
the help today sponsor this plate what's
a display the display is a super
lightweight metal poster oh it feels
cool I know it doesn't take nails
you just stick some magnets on the back
and you stick into your wall
[Music]
it's a freaking metal poster that is
magnetic and you just stick it to your
wall like so this is metal it's really
really nice I didn't realize this was on
metal what you want this your walls
would no longer cry you're not putting
holes in them you're not digging inside
of um security deposits you can get
those back let's see five seconds one
two
three four five good job so you put it
on like this yeah
yeah slap it on that's kind of fun
actually yeah I'm just trying to see
where I should put this oh yeah right
here
I want yeah we need more slappable art
like that that's awesome so not only
does this play partner with artists to
create amazing original pieces of art
but they've also partnered with some of
your favorite Brands like Halo Call of
Duty cyberpunk DC Marvel the list goes
on and on so you can be sure that
there's something for everyone
whoa oh dude miles that's sick I mean
it's literally one of the best gifts you
can give
red dude check this out this plate is
hooking our audience up using the link
in the description below you can get 25
off of one poster or 35 off of two or
more posters but that's only if you
click the link in the description below
thanks for hearing me out let's get into
react hey welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
between a little throwback today a
little return to comfort Clint's joining
us what's up guys we're back we're doing
it vfxrs react it's good to be back
how's the couch treating you it's nice
man it's comfy I don't think I've ever
it's usually been this side now now that
you are a guest you must sit in the
middle
I'm excited today we're getting into
some stuff The Last of Us of course has
been amazing such a great game first off
but also the show is incredible there's
a lot to talk about with the last of us
first off nothing's actually released
right now they're not putting stuff out
yet it's too early but the thing is the
show's sweet and it's like the game but
slightly better I'm really excited that
after that stuff with you guys heck yeah
well let's stop talking about it let's
go do it let's freaking do it
we're going to be brave and we're going
to get battles
hey let's go come on so when I was
watching the show the moment they got in
the vehicle I was like oh damn this is
like the first test of this show for me
where I'm like okay I know they're going
to recreate a sequence from the game are
they gonna pull it off though but hang
on
you're driving a real car here
I think that's blue screen that's a good
question it feels real to me it does
feel real well and there's a lot of ways
to do this sometimes you're just pulling
the vehicle with a trailer sometimes
it's on top of like a little platform or
a Go-Kart with another driver doing it
or you're in a volume doing it
these moments where all hell's breaking
loose is like it's the most thrilling
part yeah yeah where it's like there's
not a million zombies yet it's just
everyone's losing their minds it's Life
as we know it just slowly going down the
tubes basically it's about to get insane
flame fresh looks really nice that's
cool they all CG you know on the
background of that plane crashing that
lighting but the set is real because the
way the light reflects off of the
buildings on the side looks too real to
me so there is a lot of behind the
scenes footage of them filming the
sequence and they have a massive crowd
and an entire block for their set so
it's a huge environment where I think
most of what we're looking at is just
done for real practically and then this
plane crashing like it lights up the
road really nicely people always get the
lighting from explosions wrong it's like
always a giveaway is when the light
doesn't dominate especially a nighttime
scene like this they really nail the
brightness it's not just like oh a bunch
of glow but like there's Shadows being
cast and Reflections in the road it
looks like something where you could
just put a humongous light like imagine
you have a big green or blue wall back
there there's definitely a light on
they're definitely turning some big
lights on to get that effect but I think
they're also then having to go on the
road and cut out the road and take the
reflections of those lights out or at
least work it so it matches the
explosion shape yeah that would make
sense of like replacing the ground for
part of it or like adding to it you kind
of see the reflection like it's like a
wet Road and then you've got Reflections
there from that guy kind of profile I
think that's also what shows like that
they're using practical lights is
because if you're looking at the glass
on the left building there like you're
not catching the giant explosion
reflection in everything necessarily
even if they have giant lights to throw
normal practical light into the scene
and help blend everything there's no way
they're going to get the reflection of a
giant explosion on the ground if there's
nothing there so there's a lot of
rotoscoping happening with people there
in order to get that effect I mean the
fact that she lights up and her
reflection lights up accordingly like
that's that's awesome it's probably
because they're using a real giant light
on set and lighting everything up yeah
for sure well I mean this is a complex
thing to do if they're doing any sort of
compositing with these elements here and
they're not just like in a vehicle
that's going to be tough to do
like that piece of metal that flies into
the window looks like it's breaking
physics and going really slow yeah but
that's probably a thing that they have
to do in order for you to like see what
the heck is going on for story point
right it's like this little thing going
it starts off big and it gets really
tiny and they have to like turn the
motion blur down yeah it goes real slow
yeah like it slows down it speeds up
yeah it goes through the glasses
like for an otherwise Flawless scene
like that's the one thing it Rico shows
off the building into their truck and
then their truck goes upside down
the building it breaks the back
windshield
six or seven foot diameter Tire I was
like that looks so janky what the heck
here she is she's just chilling no
wheels in the shot
flying straight at them goes through the
windshield breaks through the windshield
yeah
knocks her out and then she wakes up
because they're on herself oh you
thought and look that was inside the
vehicle
the clock there in the
middle which makes sense
knocked out this little thing yeah from
the place it was like what is this like
a Walkman seriously it's like it's like
a disc man like from the 90s the show is
technically impressive but it's weird
they have a little like chunk of debris
fly all the way through the windshield
I was like she would definitely be dead
like the physics are still weird
something just flew a kilometer and then
went Boop and turned sideways maybe they
showed it like hitting the ground
bouncing and take some people doing like
a lumbering bounce to show it's like
size and scale yeah or taking some
people out this thing is going so fast
like also if you want to flip your truck
you could just have the wheel go like
this and then bounce on the truck bed
and go like you know or something like
that or like go like barrel and go like
on the back of the truck and go bear you
know yeah who who like who here thought
it went through the windshield and hit
her in the back of the head because that
was that's what I thought
[Applause]
there's an insane sequence where they
are just walking around apocalyptic
Boston and it is matte painting Heaven
my God there's so many little details
like the hanging Vines are wiggling
there all moving on the left I love this
set design they're on some sort of set
look at that so you think the car is in
or yeah but that building slab is out
right that could be a real building or
just the bottom half it could also just
be a matte painting because it's that
good yeah I don't get the feeling like
the cinematography was constrained from
VFX I don't feel like they had any shots
and stuff like we want to get a shot
like this like oh we can't the way to do
the effects so that would be too hard I
feel like everything was shot very
naturalistically as if they were just in
that situation with the set that was
built for it which like it's a really
subtle thing but you really pick up on
that in a lot of movies like we looked
at a Justice League like the end of it
you could really feel like everything
was a weird close shot of people on a
green screen because there's no
environment to like Inspire the
cinematography and you can just see like
how the decisions were shaped by it
whereas here it just feels like they
shot it as if it was all just naturally
there they're doing handheld camera
Focus pulls and things like that that
you would avoid so what makes having out
of focus matte paintings difficult is
having the light values match the Real
World style of Photography if you were
just to take like a cool image and then
make it blurry the light's not going to
react the same way because you know the
whole bokeh effect comes from an
overpowering light source getting larger
than the surrounding area you know they
start to stand out from the rest of the
image and the only way to do that is to
make sure all your matte paintings are
like either like super high bit depth
like 32-bit or something or effectively
like an HDR background plate so that way
as you're applying your depth of field
and everything to that it is able to
understand hey that white area that's
actually even wider than white you know
that's even brighter than everything
else around it so when you go out of
focus you're gonna kind of take over
that area now I would feel so stupid if
that was just part of the set and we're
just being dumb I really honestly think
that is a green screen behind them you
know you'd only construct a set that big
if you're going to have your characters
climb on it and do a big scene around it
it's like so we have this like one page
scene at the door of a building and we
had this one shot where it looks at
Pedro Pascal off to the side so we're
gonna need probably about like a half
million dollars worth of set decoration
over there for that one shot so yeah of
course they're yeah they wouldn't do
that
I mean you can kind of tell in the
sequence there's shots that are like
this is a visual effect shot the shots
that aren't a visual effect shot and
they're all subtly framed a little bit
different like that's the size of their
set right there yeah you know that's
what we're seeing like that Top Shot I
think is a good example of showing us
here's the boundaries of where we're
filming practically yeah you just tell
like a lot of the shots are framed up to
like not have visual effects this being
one of them anyways Last of Us is really
cool it's really great it's a good story
the third episode uh very unexpected
very good yeah
you want to marry my daughter
yes yes I do I got a weird one for you
guys I saw this This Kiss And This Kiss
looked weird to me and uh I'd like to
break it down with you guys and figure
out why it feels so weird may it be
fulfilled each day as you are on this
beautiful Journey so this is a big
moment in this movie This is the end of
the movie
oh no
oh no yeah they didn't kiss
like it's very subtle it probably worked
for most people but that's rough they're
using the pedals to block a lot of it
too yeah the pedals are really clearly
like be here to just cover up I can tell
you if if I was doing this shot I
wouldn't just be like just lean in and
pretend I feel like I put a little more
effort into like hitting the elements
yeah mannequin yeah or something for
your face to go like
yeah at least like the beard gets pushed
it doesn't just like you know slightly
clip into the other person her chin goes
into the beard and then goes just a
little extra yeah
it's like it's like padding like it's
padding padding padding it's like uh oh
we're clipping
here's the thing because they're
actually holding hands whose face is
doing this and then
they have to get the plate on it I think
they leaned her in more oh and he's
getting lean in more too yeah he stood
still they scooted him up to her did
they put a pivot point on his hips and
just rotate I think I think so let me
get that Pivot Point on them hips oh
yeah there's liquify on the arms for
sure it's very subtle it's only like
three degrees but they're rotating for
sure how would you guys do this shot if
you had to do this shot let me get my uh
I'll take the VFX budget that it would
take to do that and I'd be like
I can give it to you
like you kiss it if you kiss her slash
him here's it's like you go for it you
go for it
so look we got like go for it we got
like we got like 3K for this shot here I
got I stack a hundred
all right I can give this to my nephew
over here
or you know you can put this in your
pocket never say a word about it it's up
to you you want to split it with your
co-actor I mean hell yeah go 50 50. it's
a wedding
[Laughter]
and yeah so assuming they turn down your
offer
a doll I I swear no you straight up get
like a green mannequin from Old Navy
and you weigh it down real heavy so it
doesn't move yeah I mean that's the only
way to do it right I would try to
actually get some sort of like physical
interaction or they just kiss
or they kissed and something wrong
happened and they had to like fixed it
and we're just analyzing nothing
probably for covid and the comp team did
their best they probably got one take
and called it a day on set well that's
that that was great yeah yeah I thought
so too I was like wow what a golden
nugget that's great so Clinton you have
this big collaborative render challenge
project going right now right yes yes
we're doing our first actual vehicle
based render challenge right now it's
called endless engines I think there's
about three weeks left just about um for
you guys to create your own vehicle it
could be anything you want and I'm gonna
put all of the renders together into an
epic vehicle Montage so come over to the
channel learn some 3D make a cool car
and we'll see all the renders together
I got a throwback here from The Social
Network classic David Fincher movie with
some of those amazing invisible VFX Army
Hammer plays the Winklevoss twins
there's actually another actor as well
but they're twins so they need to look
the same and there's only one Army
Hammer
one of the heads is a 3D model which is
pretty Bonkers because this is 2010.
we're talking like a Straight Up 3D
model Straight Up 3D model you can see
it a little bit right on the turn you
see it it's kind of in the eyes right
there like one of the eyes kind of
starts shrinking up a little bit it's
kind of weird so what they actually did
is they basically had Army Hammer redo
the performance in this big cage of
lights and cameras and you hit a button
and they all just captured instantly so
it's a photo scan for every frame of his
performance they're doing basically a
video photo scan they're doing 24 times
a second
and then you basically get a 3D model
that's a video 3D model with the texture
of their skin everything just been
captured and projected on so there's no
like crazy texturing you have to do
there's no animation you have to do you
just get a 3D model that has the actual
video of the actor wait they're baking
they're baking the lighting into the
scene the 3D model they get of him so
all the lighting is moving around and
while it sits in this orb and just does
the expressions and they're capturing
that 24 times per second is 3D models
and literally the video of him in that
lighting is the texture you don't have
to worry about rendering the lighting
you don't have to worry about rendering
textures materials on the surface it's
all baked in the compositor must just be
like chilling so hard so thankful to be
able to get an asset like that the thing
is there's zero flexibility in this the
lighting the performance once it's
dialed in that model that's the lighting
on the model you can't show the model
from a different angle you can't
reposition it like it is locked in to
the original shot that you got they'd
have to be so sure of this technique to
bake it all in like that because you
could go get the photo scan of his head
and then work all the textures and the
shaders and whatnot but to do it this
way is it's definitely different but
that's you know in a way it's like cool
you know it obviously worked just fine
this movie's great so seriously if you
enjoy the show and chances are that you
do check out the extended cuts on
Corridor digital.com and you know we get
a little goofier we get a little riskier
that's right it gets even better on
Corridor digital.com
thank you
[Music]
you're doing this doing this guys you
know what it's time today we're gonna do
fat Rock and skinny Rock oh like the
Captain America Vibe thing the fattest
of the rocks and this the trimmest of
the Rock right
so that's the rocks look at that he's
less buff Rock he kind of looks like the
rock Obama
that's like The Rock when he doesn't go
like this too so buff son buff son comes
home
[Music]
Buffalo boy got turned into a super
beast and father AKA The Rock is injured
it looks pretty good like yeah this
looks great that's just like another guy
right I mean I feel like they just
filmed him and Compton onto somebody
else's body but like whenever they do
that it never looks very good you're
right it never looks right I think the
black and white sepia is helping them
like his face is definitely sunken I
feel his face feels like texturally a
little bit different than the body like
it kind of feels like a separate element
like the lighting kind of feels like
it's made up lighting I suppose like
actual lighting from that scene the
texture of his neck meat is different
versus the body meat yeah that's so well
done though that's crazy like that he's
looking down like that I know well it's
weird we're entering a phase now where
it's indistinguishable if you can ever
do a head replacement you gotta have
something to divide that line so is that
at VFX tactical necklace it's like you
watch the muscles on the side of his
neck like that's attached to him and
you'll see like they twitch and move but
like they don't actually move on the
other side of the necklace so like down
here is also the rock this little bit
right here yeah theoretically like when
I was watching this I was reminded of
another clip which is the exact opposite
where instead of making him really
skinny they made him super fat
oh that's so weird it's so weird oh it
is kind of like a 40 year old person's
face on a child that's so strange maybe
that's why Black Adam was so good is
because the rock did this and he
understands how the whole process works
I mean seriously I feel like this is
film him and then comp him into another
shot so it's like match Direction match
emotion unfortunately it's totally 3D
models really yeah this is all just
insane 3D models that are happening
right in his face yeah that is it's a
great 3D model too real so they you know
film the actor do all the singing all
the dancing all the acting and
expressions and what they do is the same
thing with the rock they have him go
into a big light Dome and he goes
through the entire performance as well
and then they use that as the foundation
of the animated 3D model which is then
composited back onto it for all the
stuff we're seeing in Black Adam too I
think they're doing the same thing it's
all just performance capture but then
the actual render of the face is 100 in
3D with shaders and everything we across
the line over a decade ago of just
compositing people's faces into shots
since then it's like it's 3D models and
Recreations have become the standard we
have deep fakes we have all these things
right now that are so much more
effective at accurately translating
someone's motion yeah so it's really
well done it's it's kind of a it's kind
of a mystery right now because it looks
so incredible so what has your
researched for this episode there's this
big thing happening on YouTube where
there's all these channels that are
probably using a chat gbt to summarize a
movie and it's just it is the movie with
text voice describing what's happening
like cut down to like 20 minutes and
then like the title of the video clip is
like the hook of the movie dang man
people are desperate no no no we're
seeing the like the content is about to
like die so it's kind of fun like
finding good content is gonna be like
finding a needle in a haystack while
you're out there looking for that needle
in the haystack well guess what you
already found it you're looking at it
right now so subscribe so you don't drop
it back into the haystack